Rihanna and ASAP Rocky pose with their
nine-month-old son for British Vogue and
inside the bag Riri opens up about her
relationship with the rapper I'm
honestly truly blessed Pharrell the
singer and her man Grace the March cover
wearing all black Rihanna in a long
dress with a thigh-high slit Rocky in a
vest with matching pants
fashion being creative that's one of
those things that it doesn't matter the
outlet I always enjoy it and fashion
comes like naturally but their best
accessory their baby boy whose name they
have yet to reveal what is the best part
about motherhood right now Rihanna oh my
God the morning's just like seeing his
morning face yeah and you know like
seeing a baby with like little bags and
waking up and they're just like startled
they're trying to figure out where they
at is the cutest it's my favorite part
of the day the morning the couple
welcomed their little one to the world
back in May and over the weekend ree
revealed she's expecting baby number two
during Apple music's Super Bowl halftime
show
during the Vogue interview which
happened last month before ree's second
pregnancy was revealed the Grammy winner
explained why she's grateful to have
rocky by her side telling the mag we're
best friends with a baby everything is
new to me so you know I'm excited ree
adds that while everything changes when
you have a baby it's only made them
closer it's all an exciting Journey so
far every week is something new and I'm
just taking it I'm enjoying it Andre she
can't help but gush over her man's bond
with their son quote I'm just sitting on
the sidelines when they're together I'm
literally the girl trying to get into
the boys club waiting for my turn he is
obsessed with his father and I'm like
didn't I give birth to you what is going
on sometimes I like to be in there a
little bit you know it's fun she adds
that their daddy son connection is
undeniable the second Rocky makes eye
contact with him he is on fire I realize
realized that the validation that you
really need as a boy is from your father
and while we don't know if baby number
two is a boy or a girl just yet one
thing is for sure Riri loves being a
mommy that's amazing he's a happy baby
[Music]
foreign